willkommen zur heutigen sitzung in der
wir uns mit david hume und seiner
theorie des moralischen gefühls und mit
dem smith und seiner theorie der
sympathie fassen der wir haben verleiht
fragen in welchem verhältnis stehen nach
david hume vernunft und effekte die
hatten das schon bei aristoteles
diskutiert bei seiner theorie der
ethischen tugend und
wir wollen uns auch die frage stellen
wie ich im verhältnis von duft und
moralisches gefühl stehen und vielleicht
noch am schluss einen ausblick geben auf
smith und seine theorie des
pathetischen mitgefühls vielleicht kann
man auch noch einen bezug zu francis
hodgson herstellen dass es jedenfalls
auch sehr zentral sense
gehen wir einfach mal weiter das ist
david
hat verschiedene schriften gibt verfasst
über die moralphilosophie zum einen eine
untersuchung über die prinzipien der
moral und dann den vielleicht noch
wirkmächtige
radikaleren traktat über die menschliche
natur das war so ein frühwerk der tat
und den hat damals niemand gelesen
er wurde dann aber später sehr zentral
dieser traktor und der da wo eigentlich
als das hauptwerk gelten in dem auch der
video theoretische frage behandelt nicht
nur moralphilosophen gelesen jetzt im
folgenden texte aus diesen beiden
schriften ja ich zitiere einfach mein
erstes zitat obwohl aber die vernunft
wenn sie vollständig informiert und
ausgebildet ist hinreichend sein mag uns
über die schädlichen und nützlichen
folgen von eigenschaften ganz
aufzuklären so ist sie jedoch allein
nicht hinreichend unmoralischen taten
oder moralisches tobt hervorzurufen
nutzen ist immer eine ausrichtung auf
ein bestimmtes ziel und wird das ziel
uns vollkommen gleichgültig wäre dann
würden wir dieselbe gleichgültigkeit in
gegen gefühl es ist notwendig dass ich
hier ein gefühl einstellt dass du dass
wir das nützliche dem schädlichen
vorziehen hier ist es ganz interessantes
verhältnis von vernunft und gefühl
warum er sagt die vernunft ist
nicht
hinreichend um moralischen taten oder
orange
hervorzuheben das ist natürlich eine
starke these wir finden in der
philosophiegeschichte ganz andere thesen
wie zb bei mangel kann wir kommen ob wir
noch zu sprechen der sagt die vernunft
die tadelt unmoralisches handeln genau
gesagt genau gesagt koranischen maximen
moralisches wollen ja das ist also hier
schon mal eine starke antithese zu kant
der natürlich jetzt auf jugend wollte
und sich auch nur aus diese differenz
hier verstehen lässt altes zitat dieses
gefühl kann nichts anderes sein als eine
freude über das glück der menschheit und
eine empörung über deren elend da dies
die verschiedenen ziele sind auf deren
verwirklichung tory und laster hinziehen
die vernunft belehrt uns hier über die
verschiedene tendenzen der handlung und
die menschlichkeit trifft eine
entscheidung zugunsten derjenigen
handlung die nützlich und wohl tätig
sind wir hatten es in diesem zimmer und
haben es noch in diesem seminar mit dem
thema moralisch motivation zu tun das
heißt die vernunft ich kann uns nur
belehren
also nur gewisse tendenzen von hand
gingen ja erkennen eine entscheidung
für seine motivation muss man auch sagen
für handlungen wie kann die vernunft
selbst nicht leisten die vernunft mag
vielleicht das nützliche wohltätige
erkennen aber sie mag uns nicht eine
handlungs grund dafür verfügung zu
stellen der unsere erkenntnis dann in
eine handlung überführt die entscheidung
dieses
motivation aale das hat die vernunft
nach kant schon aber nach you nicht
über these die von uns verteidigt wird
ist einfach sie besagt dass die
mobilität durch das gefühl bestimmt ist
sie definierte tugend als jede geistige
handlung oder eigenschaften einen
zuschauer
das angenehme gefühle billigung
hervorruft und das laste als dessen
gegenteil
also tugend ist eine geistige handlung
die ein gefühl
hervorruft und
die moralität ist durch das gefühl
bestimmt ja das ist natürlich eine
starke these man würde ja gemeinhin
meinen dass moral nichts mit gefühlen zu
tun hat die auch man über geschmack sich
streiten kann so sollte man sich ja über
moral gerade nicht streiten können diese
objektiv sein wie kann er jetzt durch
diese subjektivität des gefühls die
objektivität der moral begründung die
vernunft ist für uns die quelle der
erkenntnis des warmen falschen der
geschmack ist die quelle des gefühls von
schönheit missbildung laster und togo
bis heißt der geschmack oder auf das
gefühl geht in richtung der ästhetik wir
scheint jetzt die ästhetik mehr mit der
ethik in verbindung zu stehen stellen
als mit dem wahren und falschen für die
vernunft zuständig ist da die eine die
vernunft entdeckt gegenstände wie sie
wirklich in der natur vorkommen also das
skript tief ohne ihnen etwas
hinzuzufügen oder wegzunehmen der andere
nämlich der geschmack es ist ein
produktives vermögen und vergoldet oder
fährt alle natürlichen gegenständen mit
solchen farben der sich von den inneren
gefühl leid und so schöpft er ein
gewisser weise etwas neues das ist sehr
interessant also jung betont dass die
vernunft des kreativ ist nur die dinge
präsentieren kann analysieren kann wie
sie sind der verstand macht dass die
vernunft und der geschmack setzt darauf
angesetzt darauf an wie die dinge sind
er hat eine deskriptive
andiskutiert bezug aber er geht noch
weiter nämlich erfährt dass wir eine
schöne metapher erfährt diese
natürlichen gegen ständig des kreativen
gegenstände normativ könnten
also eher punkt noch etwas hinzu er
bringt noch eine wertung mit zu diesem
bloß des kreativ diese handlung kann ich
die handlung kann ich mit der fünf
beschreiben dass da irgendwas passiert
in der welt ich kann sie aber auch noch
einem bestimmten licht erscheinen lassen
indem ich sie zum beispiel werte und gut
heise kommt noch etwas zu der bloßen
deskriptive vernunft bekenntnis hinzu
und das ist etwas neues
agentur die vernunft ist kühl und
distanziert sie ist kein motiv gehandelt
und zeigt dem impuls den wir von der
lust oder der neigen empfangen nur die
mittel durch die wir glück erreichen
oder unglück vermeiden können der
geschmack wird ein motiv da haben wir es
wieder moralische motivation der
handlung ist die erste quelle oder der
erste impuls für verlangt und wollen
weil er freude oder schmerz erzeugt die
vernunft fühlen uns von den bekannten
oder vermuteten umständen und verhältnis
entdeckung des verborgenen und
unbekannten natürlich wieder nur
deskriptiv nachdem alle umstände und
verhältnisse bekannt sind lässt uns der
geschmack durch das ganze ein neues
gefühl von tadel oder lob eben nicht
erkennen das heißt die vernunft ist nie
wirklich
motivation
sondern immer nur instrumental sie kann
dem geschmack dienen dem sie ihm gewisse
mittel zur realisierung eines zwecks
gibt haben sie selbst kann nicht ein
motiv sein zumindest kein unmittelbares
die in der haltung sagt ion weiter oder
abneigung gegen einen gegenstand
entspringt aus der aussicht auf lust
oder unlust das heißt justus sind die
primären motivationsquelle und zum
handeln diese gefühle erstrecken sich
dann aber auch auf die ursachen und
wirkungen dieses gegenstand das soweit
wirklich selben durch vernunft und
erfahrung erkennen es kann für uns nicht
die geringste wichtigkeit haben zu
wissen
dass diese gegenstände ursachen sind und
jene willkommen wenn die ursachen
wirkungen uns gleichgültig sind wenn uns
die gegenstände selbst nicht applizieren
üben sie auch in ihrer verknüpfung keine
wirkung auf den willen auf die leistung
der vernunft aber besteht nichts anderem
als der entdeckung dieser verknüpfen
also ursachen und wirkungen das macht
die vernunft gegenstände mit blick auf
ursache und wirkung zu untersuchen
daraus erhält dass die gegenstände uns
nicht aufgrund der vernunft tätigkeit
offizieren können
es gibt ja immer um die frage was könnt
kann vernunft was kann geschmack oder
lust und wirst gefühle was können die
you ist hier sehr eindeutig und da die
vernunft sagte weiter allein niemals an
der handlung bezeugen oder ein wollen
auslösen kann so schließe ich dass
dieses vermögen auch nicht im stande ist
das wollen zu finden oder mit regen an
perfekte gefühl her schlecht zum streit
dies ist eine notwendige folge des
soeben gesagt und es ist ausgeschlossen
dass die vernunft die letzte wirkung die
verhinderung und wollen es anders
vollbringe als dadurch dass sie uns ein
impuls nach der und seinen effekt
entgegen gesetzten nicht und gibt wirkte
diese impuls allein zu wäre entstand das
wohnen hervor zu prüfen aber das ist
nach jungs nicht möglich dass die
vernunft ein impuls setzt der mit dem
gefühl gegen unseren willen letztendlich
dann konkurriert das werden wir gleich
noch genau zehn nichts aber kann den
impuls eines effekten zu drücken oder
verzögern als ein entgegengesetzter
impuls entspringt aber diese
entgegengesetzt impuls aus der vernunft
so muss dieses mögen auch einen
ursprünglichen einfluss auf den willen
haben und entstanden sein einen
willensakt willensakt ebenso wohl zu
erzeugen wie zu verhindern umgekehrt hat
die vernünftig einen solchen
ursprünglich um einfluss so kann sie
unmöglich einen prinzip entgegen
arbeiten dass eine solche kraft besitzt
und sie kann ebenso wenig den teils auch
nur einen augenblick von der
entscheidung zurückhaltend es erscheint
demnach als ein prinzip welches unserem
effekt entgegen tritt nicht die vernunft
selbst
dieses prinzip wird nur in uneigentlich
sinne so genannt an die vernunft ist
nicht eigentlich eine kraft die unser
handeln bestimmt sie ist keine quelle
moralischen motivation wir drücken uns
nicht genau philosophisch aus sagt ohm
mit seinem traktat jetzt wenn wir von
einem kampf zwischen effekten vernunft
rede die vernünftigsten der ist klar wie
der effekt und soll es sein sie darf
niemals eine angriffen zu beanspruchen
als die denselben zu dienen und zu
gehorchen da diese ansicht etwas
sonderbar klingen mag es nicht
unangebracht sein wenn ich sie durch
einige andere betrachtung bestätigt
und jetzt kommt eine sehr provokative
aussage von dem ich glaube ich bei jedem
von uns der oder die hierzu schaut ja
widerspruch erwecken mag sagt es läuft
der fünf nicht zuwider wenn ich lieber
die zerstörung der ganzen welt will als
einen ritt in meinem finger es
widerspricht nicht der vernunft wenn ich
meine vollständige ruhe auf mich nehme
das kleinste unbehagen eines indianers
oder einer mit gänzlich unbekannten
person zu verhindern es vertritt ebenso
wenig gegen die vernunft wenn ich das
erkannte maßen förmig und weniger guten
dem besseren vorziehen und zu den
ersteren größere neigung empfinden als
für das letzte das heißt alle
motivationsquelle stammen nur aus dem
gefühl und nicht aus der vernunft die
vernunft ist moralisch normativ völlig
in die verhält
ich könnte selbst die ganze zerstörung
der welt wollen anstatt eines kleinen
risses im empfinger das würde nicht
gegen die von 15 hier würden doch
normalerweise trotzdem seien als doch
völlig irrational was total willst nach
ruhm nicht
ja und jetzt kommen auf den nächsten
denker adams mit der hat eine theorie
der ethischen gefühle von sentiment im
jahr 17 59 verfasst wir wollen mal
schauen wie sich das jetzt zu der
beziehung verhält sagt mag man den
menschen von mox so egoistisch alten es
liegen doch offenbar gewisse prinzipien
in seiner natur dient dazu bestimmen an
dem schicksal anderer anteil zu nehmen
und die ihm selbst die glückseligkeit
dieser anderen bedürfnis machen obgleich
er keinem anderen vorteil daraus zieht
also das vergnügen zeuge davon zu sein
das geht jetzt ganz stark wie die
richtung ist konsens bei hutcherson ein
prinzip dieser art ist das erfahren oder
das mitleid das gefühl dass wir für das
elend anderer finden so bald wird dieses
entweder selbst ziehen oder sobald ist
und so lebhaft geschmiedet wird dass wir
es nach führen können dass diese
empathie das einfühlungsvermögen dass
wir oft darum komme empfinden weil
anderen menschen führt immer erfüllt
sind das ist eine tatsache die zu
augenfällig ist es dass es irgendwelche
beispiele wird dürfte um sie zu beweisen
diese empfindung ist die alle anderen
ursprünglichen effekte des menschen
keineswegs auf die tugendhaften und
normal empfinden beschränkt obgleich
diese sie vielleicht mit der höchsten
feinfühligkeit erleben würden sondern
selbst der ärgste rolle der ver härteste
verächter der gemeinschafts gesetze ist
nicht vollständig dieses gefühls war als
er wieder eine anthropologische aussage
die natürlich problematisch ist jeder
mensch egal wie sensibel er oder sie ist
der verfügt über das vermögen mitleid
und ein
und empathie zu empfinden
ja da wir keine unmittelbare erfahrung
von den gefühlen anderer menschen
besitzen das heißt es gibt einen
privilegierten zugang natürlich nur der
subjekte zu ihrer eigenen subjektivität
wir können nicht direkt in den kopf und
einmal schauen und schicke habe ich
direkt das empfinden was sie empfinden
können wir uns nur so ein bild von der
art und weise machen wie eine bestimmte
situation auch sein mag dass wir uns
vorzustellen suchen was wir selbst wurde
in der gleichen lage fühlen würde das
heißen müssen sie hineinversetzen in die
situation mag auf unser eigener bruder
auf der folge geben solange wir selbst
und wohlbefinden werden und unsere sind
niemals sagen was er leicht sie konnten
und können uns über die schranken und
zur eigenen person hinaus tragen und nur
in der fantasie können wir uns einen
begriffen derart sein empfinde machen
fantasie ist hier auch ganz wichtig ja
auch dieses zählen vermögen sagt sie
weiter kann uns auf keine andere weise
davon konnte verschaffen als indem es
uns zu bewusstsein bringt welches unsere
eigene empfindung sein würden wenn wir
uns in seiner lage befreien es sind nur
die eindrücke uns eigens sind nicht die
der heiligenbilder und so fantasie
nachbildet vermöge der einbildungskraft
sitzt wieder wichtiger begriff
einbildungskraft versetzen wir uns in
die lage mit ihrer hilfe stellen wir uns
vor dass wir selbst die gleichen marken
erlitten wie er unserer fantasie treten
mit gleichsam in seinen körper ein und
werden gewissermaßen eine person
mitglieder sehr interessante wendung
dass man hier eine person wird eine
einheit ergeben von diesem standpunkt
aus bilden wir uns eine vorstellung von
seinem findet und erleben sogar selbst
gewisse gefühle die zwar gerade nach
sprecher der partner aber den seinigen
nicht ganz unähnlich sind heutzutage
würde man aus neurophysiologische sich
sagen das sind die spiegelneuronen die
uns diese ähnlichen gefühle empfinden
lassen wenn wir so seinen qualen
gleichsam in uns aufnehmen wenn wir sie
ganz und gar zum eigenen machen dann
werden sie schließlich anfangen auf uns
ereignis gemüt einzuwirken und wir
werden zittern und er schauen bei dem
gedanken das was er jetzt fühlen mag
denn wie es uns maßlosen komma
verursacht wenn ihr selbst und sind
schmerzen und mögen irgendwelche
abfinden so wird die gleiche
gemütsbewegung in uns auch erweckt wenn
wir uns bloß in der fantasie vorstellen
dass wir in dieser lage sein und zwar in
höheren oder geringerem maße je nachdem
ob diese vorstellung lebhafte über
schwächer finden es besitzt es geht als
auch um vorstellungen die wir durch das
hineinversetzen
erfahren in die andere person und hier
wieder die fantasie ganz wichtig also
fantasie und moralischen motivation hin
interessant dass dies die quelle des
mitgefühls ist welches wir gegenüber den
elend anderen finden dass wir es dann
wenn wir mit den leidenden der fantasie
den platz tauschen dazu gelangen seine
gefühle nach zu empfinden und durch sie
innerlich berührt zu werden das kann
durch viele offenkundige beobachtung da
getan werden wenn man es nicht schon an
und für sich genügend für genügend
einleuchtend erhalten soll wenn wir zu
sehen wie in diesem augenblick jemand
gegen das bein und den arm eines anderen
zum schlag ausholt dieser schlag eben
auf den anderen niedersausen soll dann
zucken wir ungepflegtes haben und ziehen
unser eigenes bein oder unseren eigenen
arm zurück und wenn der schlag den
anderen trifft dann fühlen wir ihnen in
gewissem maße selbst der schmerzen
ebenso wohl wie den betroffenen das ist
unser einfühlungsvermögen wir können uns
mit unserer fand dass die in dieser
situation selbst hinein versetzen aber
nicht nur solche umstände die schmerz
oder kummer hervorrufen erwirken unser
mitgefühl den effekt der durch irgendein
gegenstand der zunächst betroffenen
person erregt wird mag vielmehr welche
immer seien stets wird in der brust
eines jeden aufmerksam zuschauen mit dem
gedanken an die lage des anderen eine
ähnliche gemütsbewegung entstehen unsere
freude über die errettung jener
tragödien oder romanhelden die unsere
anteilnahme bitten ist jedem so
aufrichtig wie unser kummer wie ihre not
und das mitgefühl mit ihren event ist
nicht wirklich als das mit ihrem glück
wir teilen ihre dankbarkeit gegenüber
jenen treuen freunden die sie ihren
bedrängnissen nicht verlassen und von
ganzem herzen empfinden wir ihre für ihr
verletzungs gefühl gegen jene treulosen
verrät die sie beleidigt im stich
gelassen oder getrunken haben der alle
effekten deren das menschliche gemüt
fähig ist entsprechen die gemütsbewegung
des zuschauers immer die bilder dass
dieser sich von den empfindungen des
leidenden macht indem er sich in dessen
fall hinein denkt man müsste vielleicht
genauer sagen hineinfühlen
ist ja hier jetzt nicht die quelle der
moralische bewertung erbarmen und
mitleid sind werte die dazu bestimmt
sind unser mitgefühl mit dem kummer
antrag zu bezeichnen das wort sympathie
kann dagegen obgleich seine bedeutung
vielleicht ursprünglich die gleiche war
jetzt doch ohne vorstoß gegen den
sprachgebrauch dazu verwendet werden um
unser mitgefühl mit jeder art von
effekten zu bezeichnen
also die sympathie wird jetzt von
mitleid und erbarmen unterschieden das
ist also
ein
vermögen
anzumelden
mitgefühl mitglieder art von effekten zu
bezeichnen als egal ob es positive oder
negative effekte sind die die andere
person besetzt in manchen fällen mag es
den anschein haben das sympathie aus dem
bloßen anblick einen bestimmten
gemütsbewegung an einer anderen person
entstehen in manchen film mag es
geradezu scheinen dass die effekte sich
in einem augenblick von einem menschen
auf einen anderen übertragen und zwar
bevor dieser irgendwelche kenntnis davon
hat was ist das in der zunächst
betroffenen person jede effekte auslöst
kummer und freude zum beispiel wirken
wenn sie im blick und gebärden eines
menschen stark zum ausdruck kommen auch
im zuschauer sofort eine gleiche
schmerzliche oder freudige
gemütsbewegung eines gewissen grades ein
lächelndes gesicht blick auf jeden der
sieht aufhalten eine sorgenvolle mienen
anders als erwartet traurigkeit dh die
moralische motivation können wir durch
sympathie leisten dies geht indessen
nicht allgemein und die witzigen effekt
es gibt perfekte deren ausdruck
keinerlei sympathie hervorruft film viel
mehr er die wirkung hat und schon wider
willen und unsere abmahnung zu erwecken
so lange wir nicht mit der ursache der
effekte bekannt sind das löten der
benehmen eines zornigen würden es wurde
ihr gegen ihn selbst aufbringen als
gegen seine feinde also effekte sind
nicht die wurzel nicht die quelle
moralische notsituation sondern
sympathie deshalb die partie setzt immer
auch ein einfühlen ein verstehen voraus
und jetzt kann man sich fragen ob dieses
verstehen ich wiederum auf unsere
vernunft
irgendwie ins spiel bringen lässt da wir
nicht wissen was sei herausgefordert hat
können wir uns in seinen fallen nicht
hineindenken wir sehen uns hinein denken
fantasie hat nicht nur was mit gefühl zu
tun sondern eben auch mit dem denken
hier sehen wir dass beides misst gefühl
und vernunft wieder eine ganz komplexe
weise zusammenwirken der moralischen
motivation können es nicht hineindenken
darum auch keine neidgefühle finden die
den effekten gleichen würden wege diese
herausforderungen im auslöst wir sehen
da geht ganz klar die lage derjenigen
personen für uns gegen welche sind zwar
an sich richtet und können uns
vorstellen welche gewalttätigkeiten sie
wohl zu einem so den gegner gewärtigen
müssen darum sympathisieren wir mit
ihren früchten ihren vergeltungs gefühl
sind sofort bereit gegen den mann partei
zu ergreifen seien bestens seite ihm
eine so große gefahr zu tun scheint also
hier wir sehen ganz klar die lage das
ist natürlich auch etwas was mit
urteilskraft zu tun hatten mit 5 und mir
natürlich auch uns hinein denn ja ja
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit wir
setzen diese diskussion dann fort gerne
auch hier unten in der beschreibung in
youtube